hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Santa plier the game I
have to collect gifts for all the
kiddies that's the most adorable thing
I've ever seen and I recognize that fan
art it was one of the ones I use for
Christmas uh this past year but anyway
let's get honey
all right you could easy
oh I thought there was gonna be more to
that oh god you kitties don't control
very nicely do ya okay so it was left
mouse button to speed up oh good god
this is not control well okay I think I
missed the presence oh my god is that
the oh my god that's the extra epic sax
music guy bang coming okay why did I
moan with such a visceral pleasure I
have no idea what's going on with those
kitties in Santa Claus over there or
you'll dime curds
stop stop stirring you got into the
eggnog didn't you oh it was right there
god this is hard that's what she said
I don't know what to do my normal voice
our Santa Claus voice
I dragged fine what this is really hard
oh my god okay so I just okay
oh that epic sax music is so not
Christmassy but I what is the point of
even rotating Oh burn fana really
appreciate the nice soft tender Previn
for all the little boys and girls got it
hey you know I've done so okay slow down
slow down slow down slow down slow down
okay you came to a complete stop you're
floating in the air that's all good and
you kids are so creepy with your
constant running God you look like a
little gremlins okay you know what says
it's gonna fly upside down from now and
anyway this is made by the same guy that
made
yeah that's what thought okay this is
Mabel oh god sometimes I'm done no get
the pattern get it stop being such an
[ __ ] I didn't expect this to be a
goddamn rage game you son of a [ __ ]
just I've already played my rage game
for the day Jesus is so difficult
this Gordon aid oh my god it's
impossible it gets it good Lord a low it
is just line up good hide I'm still not
lined up am i I'm still not Frick
fragging line up there we go
oh my god you you guys can't even see
how this translated into the game
because this game is just ridiculously
hard to control no oh god I've been
blowing out the mic since I started
playing this Avenue I am very sorry I've
got I've been monitoring my voice but
it's not work at all oh my god you son
of a [ __ ]
do me this game I knew you made other
ones but did you intentionally make is
the worst control game I've ever played
in my life
ah I hate oh god I hate everything right
now no no don't miss it I miss it
I have to go in a goddamn corkscrew to
be able to get the AH I don't want to
have to do that I don't want to have to
do this this isn't fine this isn't fine
okay I got it okay
panic time over let's just take it back
for a breather it'd be nice if I could
see more than like presences
constellations on the edge of horizon
okay I'm gonna calm down now because
I've learned I've learned to tame the
beasts within and control these diam
cutters so that they fly a normal
direction
is that bad ass bastard cuz don't know
what's good for them I'm gonna put
nutmeg in their stockings you know what
I mean everybody even I don't know what
I mean they're not so crazy you don't
know what he's gonna do
gods I know that Santa voice is gonna
destroy my voice later on oh I'm not
gonna be able to talk for like five days
cut I know why Santa oner oh now stop so
okay do you are you seeing this guys are
you understanding and appreciate what I
am suffering through right now to make
sure that I get to the end of this
goddamn game are you understanding now
do you get it
do you understand Bay oh my god it is so
frustrating it's that feeling goes down
up top top top top top please hey hey
hey the effects sack music it's none of
my business endeavor Oh be nice I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not wanting
to be a god oh [ __ ] I'm not wanting to
be go oh my god is so from it's oh it's
like so frustrating just to try to get
it to go exactly where you want it to go
okay stop stop stop it doesn't stop when
you want to do it doesn't turn where you
want to do it doesn't go what you wanted
to do just stop oh god oh god it's the
most frustrating thing I've ever done in
my entire life
oh my god I've never been in this much
agony playing a game just trying to
finagle it's like playing inverted with
a Russian controller in a Russian and
struggling battle it's 100% communist
right now good Lori I didn't know the
Santa I should have guessed with all the
red on his coat I just thought it with
the blood of the innocents but
apparently it's just him showing his
true colors
okay I think I'm oddly enough I think
I'm actually getting the hang of it I'm
stuck god you know that feeling that you
get when you're trying to get something
it's like trying to thread a needle
through the hole of a pin and it's
literally so infuriating that you need
to set it down and go lay down and take
a nap
that's how infuriating that was it's a
little better now because I'm getting a
feel for it
guess by the last two presents I got a
feel for it now I'm adjusting I'm happy
someone made me a game I blew out all
the eardrums of my fans in the beginning
Oh Oh God
if I hit the mountainside and died if
that's how that game would end it right
before I would have got them last one I
would have been you know oh my god stop
giving me a goddamn heart attack
please I better get back the normality I
want to go back to a happy life I'll
live happy well it free okay oh okay
Oh what nice music when they send her
music it's good
oh that's good okay okay all right
so anyway I'm sorry I got mad at you
review for a Granger but a lil if you
understand
hmm don't get me wrong this music is
actually quite soothing for me it's very
nice
let's all just take a relaxing breath
get rid of all the stress you know when
I went into this game what I knew it was
gonna be Santa player of the game I was
gonna do like oh I got so many Santa
jokes that I'm gonna make hell it's
gonna be so much fun faith pants you're
gonna love it but either way this was
crazy awesome and I hope you guys got a
laugh out it's all good fun I don't mean
to be insulting to the developer
developer you've made two great games
for me in the past I cannot be more
grateful to you and to everyone that has
made me anything fanart
of videos attribute things and games
like all that I am so honored because
this community is so awesome and I
didn't mean for this to turn into like a
vlog but the music's here so might as
well you guys are amazing seriously
thank you so much for everything that
you've done to support me and also I see
there's bard actor1 down there just
thank you guys so much for doing all
this for me you're awesome he's awesome
bard actors awesome all of you are
awesome so thank you all so much you can
play this for yourself and you can see
how frustrating it was in the
description below baby the way the
music's gonna have so thank you all so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video little late
awkward silence
Derner dubsmash me ground I haven't been
able to get more